bonjour bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen pour ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
focus aujourd'hui sur l'allemagne
l'allemagne face à la crise des migrants
sokü sous un angle économique et vous
allez le voir nous allons aller à
l'encontre de bien des idées reçues et
si les migrants les réfugiés était une
chance pour l'économie allemande en
particulier une chance pour l'économie
européenne en général outre râle le
patronat allemand est le premier
supporter des migrants grâce aux
migrants il peut combler un déficit de
main d'oeuvre
un déficit d'apprentis comme vous allez
le voir dans ce reportage d'elisa
berthelot mai en allemagne près de berre
la regarder
nous sommes dans le brandebourg une
région proche de berlin filmé le garde
et le patron de ruiter stc une
entreprise spécialisée dans la
fabrication d'éoliennes à côté de son
usine un foyer d'hébergement de réfugiés
notre entreprise se situe à côté d'un
foyer de réfugiés nous les avons souvent
vu traîner dans la rue ou n'avaient rien
à faire et on s'est dit qu'il fallait
leur trouver une occupation début 2015
le pdg décide donc d'investir il propose
un programme de formation à douze
d'entre eux trois mois d'initiation à la
soudure et d'apprentissage de la langue
allemande
à la sortie du court film elle garde en
a gardé quatre parmi eux francis
d'origine camerounaise soit des
nombreuses absences
l'entreprise compte 330 employés dont 15
% d'étrangers de toutes origines pologne
slovaquie liban en somalie tchad une
main d'oeuvre plus que nécessaire une
situation gagnant gagnant pour
l'entrepreneur je peux vous dire que si
je n'avais pas c'est étrange il dans mon
entreprise il me serait impossible de
les remplacer par des travailleurs de
cette région alors que faire est-ce que
je dois refuser des contrats des
commandes donc il faut bien le dire si
mon entreprise veut gagner de l'argent
j'ai besoin de ces étranges mais pour
travailler en allemagne les étrangers
doivent d'abord décrocher le précieux
sésame
un titre de séjour des documents
attendus par les centaines de milliers
de réfugiés arrivés dans le pays depuis
le début de l'année berlin doit en
accueillir quarante mille dans ce centre
social de la capitale
ils sont plusieurs centaines à attendre
leurs papiers lorsqu'ils arrivent sur le
territoire allemand
un réfugié doit patienter minimum trois
mois avant de pouvoir travailler une
période que l' agence pour l'emploi met
à profit pour lancer les premières
démarches d'abord
et améliorer le niveau d'allemand les
connaissances de l'on doive être niveau
b2 dans le cadre de référence des
langues européennes
ensuite il ya des possibilités de
prendre des courses de qualifications
pour pouvoir s'intégrer dans le marché
allemand mais une fois que le status est
clair ils sont prêtés comme tous les
autres clients de l'agencé d'emploi
comme les amants ou peut-être comme les
français qui vivent ici
mais il est parfois difficile pour un
réfugié de trouver un emploi à la
hauteur de ses compétences
georgette ingénieurs avec sa famille
ceci rien de 50 ans a fui la ville de
homs pour l'allemagne en 2012 malgré un
bon niveau d'allemand et de
qualification impossible pour lui de
retrouver un travail dans l'ingénierie
civile
malheureusement mon diplôme et mes
études n'ont pas pu être reconnue car je
n'avais pas mes relevés de notes mais
comme j'avais de bonnes connaissances en
allemand je me suis dit que je pourrais
faire autre chose s'est trouvé une
nouvelle voie forcément les réfugiés
syriens ont besoin d'alliés georges a
donc choisi d'être traducteurs arabes
aux allemands pour aider les autres
réfugiés comme lui malgré la précarité
de sa situation il ne regrette pas son
choix
aujourd'hui le plus important c'est que
ma famille soit en sécurité
mes enfants peuvent aller à l'école ici
le plus jeune 20 à la crèche ils se
sentent bien ici et ils auront toutes
les possibilités dans la vie qui
pourront faire tout ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire
schaaf benzidane vol
car avant même de trouver un travail le
but premier de tous ces migrants c'est
d'obtenir le statut de réfugié
à ce moment là seulement ils pourront
envisager de se construire un avenir
voilà un sujet a signé lisa bertolo mais
nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau trois
eurodéputés d'abord nathalie griesbeck
bonjour vous êtes députée française élu
sous les couleurs du modem
vous revenez à d'une mission sur les
migrants aux balkans vous nous
raconterez à vos côtés un eurodéputé
allemand jo leinen bonjour vous êtes
social démocrates du spd le parti de
gauche qui forme avec la cd ou la grande
coalition au pouvoir en allemagne avec à
sa tête angela merkel et puis enfin
louis aliot députés français du groupe
europe des nations et des libertés à
vous êtes membre du front national tête
de liste aux régionales également alors
vous venez de voir le reportage d'elisa
bertolo mes questions toutes simples
pour commencer ce que les migrants c'est
une chance pour l'économie allemande en
particulier pour l'économie européenne
en général jo leinen
bon d'abord c'est un grand problème
lorsqu'on a un million et plus tu micron
année alors il faut les intégrer dans le
système allemagne oui d'éducation dans
le système a sombré mais vous avez
raison c'est aussi une chance c'est une
chance pour les migrants font ce qu'ils
peuvent rester dans notre pays ils
peuvent trouver un travail et peuvent
avoir une meilleure vie pour leurs
familles et c'est une chance pour
l'allemagne parce que la démographie
joue contre nous en europe contre nous
en allemagne opération vieillissante en
allemagne donc une main d'oeuvre jeune
c'est assez positif lavelli griesbeck
une chanson un défi un défi pour
l'europe à un défi à relever c'est une
forme de chance
et moi je fais confiance je pense à ceux
qui respectent bien les traités qui
respectent nos valeurs humanistes pour
permettre une insertion de gens qui sont
en partie diplômés le documentaire le
montrer bien et donc une
une façon de répondre à ce problème qui
touche tous les européens et dont j'ai
vu la réalité mois en en étant aux
différents postes frontières dans les
balkans des situations terribles des
gens qui sont comme vous et moi qui
fuient la guerre la violence la barbarie
et qui répondent pour une partie d'entre
eux aux critères des demandeurs d'asile
avec bon on en reparlera peut-être une
organisation à mettre en oeuvre sur le
sujet sur le fond qu un migrant une
soeur une chance pour l'économie
allemande pour l'économie européenne
je soupçonne votre désaccord louis aliot
écoutez d'abord ils sont le reflet de
notre propre erreur dans la politique
internationale
beaucoup de déstabilisation de sept de
ces pays l'ont été par l'action il faut
qu'elle veut dire des états unis et de
la france c'est vrai pour l'irak
c'est vrai pour la libye c'est vrai pour
la syrie avec les conséquences que nous
avons aujourd'hui
donc ça c'est le premier point le
constat il est c'est notre
responsabilité comme d'ailleurs en
afrique un certain deux dictateurs sont
maintenus par les réseaux de corruption
entretenu par nos dirigeants occidentaux
ça c'est la première pole le deuxième
point ils sont là je ne vois pas comment
je devais parler que pour la phrase
l'allemagne mon collègue allemand a dit
que c'était une chance je ne vois pas
comment avec 6 millions de chômeurs 9
millions de pauvres et des difficultés
d'intégration des populations d'autres
cultures et d'autres religions parce
qu'en face de ce problème se pose
aujourd'hui avec une avec acuité
je me demande comment nous allons
pouvoir intégrer ces dizaines de
milliers voire des centaines joly sur le
sur le calme le député le disais c'est à
ces populations est vieillissant et je
sais ta mort de main d'oeuvre jeune je
m'excuse ailleurs le patronat allemand
est justement c'est le premier supporter
justement migrants c'est bien le
problème le patronat allemand est
heureux parce qu'il va pouvoir
accueillir une main d'oeuvre bon marché
pour être compétitif et on a des lois
des smic
aussi c'est à dire on respecte les lois
et les règles de l'allemagne et mais
bien sûr ce qu'ils peuvent rester de
droit d'asile
aussi selon la convention des nations
unies les réfugiés des guerres
il faut faire quelque chose avec ces
gens il faut pas les laisser dans des
camps dans des ghettos et de les
intégrer dans le marché du travail dans
d'autres emplois c'est notre mission
humanitaire aussi et pas seulement
économique
je disais que l'allemagne était
accueillante puisque il y aurait un
retournement après avoir ouvert sa porte
aux syriens les allemands se rétracte
ils disent avoir peur des réfugiés en
gala merkel chute dans l'opinion
regarder on réagit juste après
angela merkel en costume de nazis ou en
mère teresa version terroristes plus de
9000 personnes battent le pavé
rassemblement hebdomadaire addressed à
l'est de l'allemagne pour son premier
anniversaire le mouvement allemand
islamophobe peggy da multiplie les
attaques contre la chancelière allemande
elle est qualifiée de bonne femme
irresponsable pays d'à demande sa
démission
madame merkel doit absolument partir
car elle déshonore son mandat elle en
laisse rompre et toujorus elle crève le
peuple ce pays a été construit par nos
parents et nos grands parents et nous
allons le garder tel quel nous voulons
rester un pays chrétien
après avoir ouvert ses portes aux
syriens
les allemands se rétracte une majorité
d'allemands disent avoir peur des
réfugiés et merkel chute dans l'opinion
la presse relaie un chiffre 7 millions
de réfugiés sont à prévoir à terme avec
le regroupement familial
les incidents dans les centres d'accueil
des bagarres dans les files d'attentes
finissent par retourner l'opinion
allemande contre mundi merkel maman
merkel même si beaucoup
continue à tendre la main on ne peut pas
aller faire la guerre là-bas forcer les
gens à fuir et ensuite leur ferme la
porte
ces quelques années la nécessité
d'épauler un point illustration du
retournement de situation cette séquence
angela merkel dans un centre d'accueil
qui laisse les réfugiés la photographier
le message les réfugiés sont le bienvenu
aujourd'hui on reproche à la chancelière
d'avoir posé en mère teresa pour
quelques scènes et même la télé s'y met
pour illustrer un reportage sur la crise
des migrants ard première chaîne
germanique met en scène un photomontage
avec une longue et la merkel voilée et
en tchador devant un bundestag hérissée
de minarets
ou quand la télé publique on fait aussi
du pegi tas
voilà mais la télé publique fait duper
guide à john allen on assiste vraiment à
revirements dans l'opinion allemande les
allemandes de plus des migrants non
c'est pas vrai il faut distinguer les
trois d'asile ceux qui sont réfugiés des
guerres je crois là il ya une grande
ouverture dans notre population et la
vague d'immigration pour d'autres
raisons disons pour trouver un meilleur
vie alors je crois il faut mieux
s'organiser pour garantir le droit
d'asile qui est dans notre constitution
d'ailleurs et disons d'autres micro ou
en effet on a un problème parce qu'on ne
peut pas réécrire tout le monde qui est
pauvre au monde
dr on attend 800 mille réfugiés en
allemagne cette année
24000 seulement pour la france pourquoi
cette différence là tels que lisbeth
parce que la halle allemagne avec la
chancelière est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'allemands a décidé de
proposer à ces demandeurs d'asile à ces
réfugiés de venir en allemagne dans sur
la route des balkans encore une fois
entre la grèce la macédoine la serbie et
la hongrie
toutes les familles qui étaient par
milliers sur les routes que j'ai croisés
voulait-elle et soit en suède soit en
allemagne répondre en fait à la demande
de la chancelière mais je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui vient d'être dit et
sur les images de l'extrême droite qui
s'oppose
c'est vrai que manifestations tous les
lundis voilà oui mais dix mille
personnes à chaque fois on a correspond
à une parade rays haute opinion publique
et moi je voudrais saluer le courage de
la chancelière qui a la garde son cap
oui et à la fois répond donc aux traités
et propose d'accueillir les réfugiés de
les distinguer les migrants économiques
qui doivent être renvoyés dans leur pays
ils sont dans des situations difficiles
mais pas d'urgence et pas dans le cadre
des traités et des
et des normes internationales auxquelles
nous avons décidé nous les européens de
répondre est de nous conformer mais il
elle elle a du courage et là elle a vu
aussi quels étaient les objectifs qui
peuvent être poursuivis pour son pays et
moi je salue cette détermination c'est
le sens politique
après c'est vrai qu'ils sont nombreux
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle n'a
pas demandé qu'on ferme les frontières
absolument pas elle a demandé à ce qu'on
restaure le contrôle puisque si vous
aviez comme moi été voir sur le terrain
et si vous n'étiez pas juste dans
l'anathème et ses invités - d'un voyage
je viendrai tiebing cc vous pouvez tout
à fait vous rendre compte c'est très
facile de faire de la démagogie en
surfant sur la peur c'est autrement plus
difficile d'exercer en politique
la démagogie témoin non qu'on peut
intervenir tout le vent ne trouvant du
travail alors qu'il n'y a plus d'eau
n'est pas ma posture démagogie sur le
terrain des milliers de gens réfugiés
avec des des images qui sont si les pam
est aujourd'hui une guerre aujourd'hui
on sait que tous ces réfugiés ne fuyait
pas la guerre une partie dans des
rêveries que je dis est que ces zones
manquant ya en ce moment là et jo leinen
il me sembla dit la même chose et nous
ne sommes pas nécessairement du même
groupe politique
nous devons nous ne pouvons pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde mais
nous devons y prendre notre part ce
qu'avait déjà l'euro car je vous rassure
mais vous entendez la phrase est moi
elle me va très très bien
elle devrait vous allez oust signer un
jour une rassure tout de suite puisque
nous sommes français tous les deux je
n'ai rencontré aucun réfugié qui
souhaitaient venir en france
ils veulent tous aller en alemagne a
donc en grande bretagne j'ai eu aussi un
peu en grande bretagne et beaucoup en
suède les cornichons assystem europe on
discute sur le cheese rentière
alexandrie q les âges
le show est leur ennemi mère externe
chiffres qui le chiffre des réfugiés je
soutiens que la france et de l'accueil
plus de 200000 déjà par an donc ça
s'ajoute à l'immigration légale entre
guillemets notre territoire regardez
monsieur les sens artistique de ligne
c'est l'afflux migratoire je vous l'avez
vu vous en 96 milles qui quittent le
territoire national alors par mails
d'agiter la peur la france n'a plus cité
lapin économique d'accueillir les
réfugiés ou une immigration
supplémentaires il faut que ça se sache
man mais il bat l'allemagne a fait une
erreur madame merkel par ce n'est pas
par humanisme nous paraît une terrible
avec le grand patronat allemand aa
commence à peine à créer un appel d'air
et beaucoup de gens sont venus en
croyant qu'ils allaient trouver en
allemagne et tout d'un coup du travail
un logement une éducation tous les sens
on a transféré le problème ils partent
deux camps au liban en jordanie en
turquie pour se retrouver en allemagne
et un dans des bandes et sans n'y a pas
que des sandales dorées thaçi raconte
monsieur france regardez ce qui se passe
à calais regardez c'est pas ça que ça
devrait aller
c'est une honte si c'est pas ça qu'elle
est alors on suit ton 16 05
mais ce champ trois millions comme
arrêter avec vos formules d'appel d'air
etc qui sont empreintes de 2,2
non mais vous c'est l'humanisme d'argent
des as du tice est facile il faut
restaurer le contrôle aux frontières
externes de l'europe
enfin les états sont d'accord avec des
hotspots l'enregistrement et c est
ensuite accueillir ce qu'on peut
accueillir économiquement change dur de
dix courses accueillir et pas du tout je
suis comme toi et jonah hill valley la
même chose il faut distinguer entre les
réfugiés qui fuient la guerre et les
migrants économiques
l'armée quant à décider des règles
européens et que les règles sont pas
respectés alors la régie stration des
immigrants aux portes de l'europe dix
ans et ça il faut organiser en sort le
jour une solidarité à démarrer
injustement merkel et françois hollande
était la semaine dernière au parlement
devant le parlement européen un discours
historique à ça fait 26 ans qui ne
s'était pas adressé aux députés
européens angela merkel on a parlé donc
de dublin 1 du droit d'asile angela
merkel qui dit que c est obsolète
presque obsolète
je rappelle dublin des accords de dublin
c'est l'idée selon laquelle les réfugiés
quand ils arrivent c'est au pays où il
arrive qu'ils doivent déposer leur
demande de droit droit d'asile c'est
donc au pays d'arrivée de traiter la
demande d'asile du du réfugié donc c'est
obsolète
la réseau marseillais en fait oui
c'était les grecs les italiens qui ont
une initiation il faut une innovation
développement la raison système d'asile
et d'immigration en europe et c'est une
responsabilité commune c'est pas la
responsabilité d'un pays aux deux autres
parce que la migration et ce système en
fait ça favorisait la france et l
allemagne puisqu'il arrivait directement
transférées à favoriser tous ceux qui
sont fondues externe italie malte grèce
organiser un sommet européen de
solidarité pour vraiment disons gagner
ce défi qui qui est juste au
commencement c'est pas la fin la
migration de l'afrique du moyen orient
on peut pas expects et ça que ça finit à
noël ou au nouvel an alors je crois à
l'europe on a besoin de plus d'europe et
pas comme les souverainistes is de moins
d'europe
le contraire est juste c'est lui c'est
une formule ça le droit d'asile ou trois
ans auront des nations a plus d'europe
communautaire la serrure et je pense que
le problème migratoire tôt pour le
mondial et qui ne fait que commencer
mais c'est l'américain l'arrivée la
responsabilité notamment de la france et
des pays européens c'est aussi ne pas se
comporter en afrique ou dans les pays du
moyen-orient comme ils se comportent
aujourd'hui de tenir compte d'un certain
nombre de réalités de de ne pas aller
agité un certain nombre de querelles et
dont on voit aujourd'hui les résultats
je rappelle que la lie
aujourd'hui la déstabilisation de la
libye par monsieur sarkozy et le
gouvernement monsieur ça que jamais a
occasionné ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui en partie il faut arrêter de
jouer avec l'afrique de faire confiance
à une jeunesse qui se lève en afrique
qui veut développer le continent parce
que cet angle des serrures évidemment le
l'économie en afrique qu'on ne
desserrera l'étau migratoire juste un
petit mot par exemple dans le congo
brazzaville aujourd'hui vous avez un
chef d'état ça fait 30 ans qu'il est là
la constitution lui interdit de faire un
troisième mandat il est en train de
modifier la constitution
avec la complicité du gouvernement
français et bien tout ça il faut que ça
s'arrête
et vite mais ça c'est une banalité le
fait qu'on ne le fait ça c'est quelque
chose que vous faites ou quelqu'un fait
tout de suite alors le droit d'asile
dublin il ya aussi schengen a le
contrôle aux frontières alors cela c'est
françois hollande la semaine dernière
dans son discours qui propose la
création d'un corps de fonctionnaires
gardent de européen de garde frontières
européens donc bonjour à 68 on va pas
créer des fonctionnaires supplémentaires
qui devront aller les envoyer aux
frontières c'est mutualiser les moyens
de l'union européenne pour que ce soit
pas simplement les grecs ou les idées ou
les italiens qui paye
vous pensez que c'est réaliste
absolument il faut il faut vraiment
avoir l'idée pour l'avenir dé faire un
système commun delà du contrôle des
frontières de l'union européenne
parce que lorsqu'on veut avoir la
liberté entre nos pays et moi j'habite à
ça près qu'à la frontière vers forbach
et la lorraine
et ça me fait d'où leur cas à la
frontière sur l'autoroute il ya de
nouveau quelques contrôles c'est pas
systématique mais quand même
cheyenne c'était un atout énorme pour la
population européenne et il faut pas
perdre sénatrice bac la vieillesse avec
votre mission dans les balkans schengen
c'est l'europe et il faut plus sera plus
d'europe en terme de solidarité entre
les états membres et modifier dublin
parce que on ne peut pas laisser
quelques pays supporter seul donc c'est
cet accueil c'est logique dans j'ai tué
la poule avec zéro avec la hongrie vous
me disiez c'est terrible c'était
terrible
côté des milliers de gens qui se
dépêchait d'essayer de transiter par des
états membres et des états non parce que
la macédoine et la serbie ne sont pas
membres de l'union et qui essayez
d'arriver en hongrie et la hongrie qui
souhaitait faire ce que la grèce n'avait
pas fait c'est à dire un enregistrement
et une possibilité de d'accueillir les
gens correctement et de distinguer
encore une fois entre les migrants
économiques pour lesquels donc l'europe
n'a pas la capacité pour l'instant les
moyens de les accueillir et les réfugiés
terrible et nous avons un devoir
d'humaniste il suffit on va revenir et
sur le lait renversé
qu'est ce qu'on fait comment est ce
qu'on avance justement on est tous
d'accord pour dire que ça n'est qu'un
début ces flux ses clés s'il ya eu des
soucis c'est bien parce qu'ils sont très
nombreux et qu'il faut apporter des
réponses et bravo un certain nombre de
gouvernants français sur les
gardes-côtes pour briser mois sur les
garde-côtes c'est une idée qu'on est
nombreux de porter depuis des années au
parlement européen tant mieux si tout à
coup des états membres membres du
conseil le proposer ça n'est pas la
seule réponse il faut un ensemble jeudi
le discours historique la semaine
dernière du duo franco-allemand et on
assistait à un clash entre marine le pen
et françois hollande c'est assez inédit
puisque à l'assemblée nationale
président la république peut pas
s'adresser aux députés la séparation des
pouvoirs oblige au parlement européen
c'est possible on assiste à un clash je
vous propose d'écouter ont réagi juste
après
merci madame merkel de nous faire le
plaisir de venir aujourd'hui avec votre
vice chancelier administrateur de la
province france monsieur le vice
chancelier
j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous appeler
monsieur le président de la république
par respect pour votre fonction mais pas
plus que votre prédécesseur vous
n'exercez cette présidence un président
de la république ne pourrais pas dire le
souverainisme c'est le déclinisme comme
vous venez de le faire la seule voie
possible pour celles et ceux qui ne sont
pas convaincus de l'europe c'est de
sortir de l'europe tout simplement c'est
il n'y a pas d'autre voie et et celle là
elle est terrible mais elle est celle
finalement de la logique de sortir de
l'europe de sortir de l'euro de sortir
de schengen
et même si vous pouvez de sortir même de
la démocratie parce que parfois en vous
entendant je me pose cette question
alors madame messieurs est ce que
question simple à marine le pen a
insulté deux chefs d'état il l'a
totalement comme elle fait toujours
c'est une politique d'incitation vers
l'europe
les hommes et femmes qui portent l'idée
de l'europe et c'est incroyable que on a
de telles personnes au parlement
européen si on parle mais on peut plus
parler ça va être difficile que bon mais
il faut un débat démocratique
vous savez on peut c'est la décharge au
fel que fois c'est vif mais là bas mais
là mais de la manière louis aliot quand
même administrateur de la province
française
hu a l'impression que marine le résident
de dire les mots accusant troisième
reich du président la république
domination allemands et six dans la
république qui est le garant de nos
institutions
venez de dire que la souveraineté
c'était dépasser le titre 1 de notre
constitution s'appelle de la
souveraineté
il a parlé de souveraineté d'aller plus
haut lieu d'effacer la souveraineté
après la villa souverainisme
souverainisme donc je veux dire le débat
c'est un débat
quelquefois il il est vif c'est normal
faut pas s'inquiéter car les débats sont
vifs
il faut s'inquiéter car les mesures ne
sont pas prises et que la politique qui
est menée par la gauche au pouvoir mène
au désastre économique social et même
humain aujourd'hui réglé ses comptes
avec la république devant les européens
mais c'est pas un monde de bisounours
c'est pas on n'est pas là le problème
c'est vous dire c'est qu'on est dans une
europe ici où monsieur juncker est élu
grâce aux socialistes et où le président
du parlement européen et élue grâce aux
gens de la droite
elle est là la collusion et de
complicité entre les deux alors dès que
vous avez des gens qui arrivent et qui
vient de milieux pour contester leur
système ils sont pas contents quelle que
soit la manière dont nous contester le
système par ailleurs il est là le
problème en europe où il n'y a pas débat
tant d être patriote c'est les mots qui
ont été dits face aux chefs d'états de
d'un grand pays membres de l'union
européenne et au mépris à l'égard de
madame merkel chancelière d'un autre
membre de l'union européenne est
inadmissible
vous essayez en permanence sous couvert
de parler vous sous couvert de du droit
de parole de toujours de diriger l'un
des surnoms
on trees and ideas je suis triste en
tant que française de voir une française
s'exprimer avec ce mépris et cette
mauvaise éducation sur un territoire sur
it war européen
je trouve qu'on peut pas se dire
patriotes et faire des choses les chefs
natural est ce que vous ne dites pas ce
que marine a parlé mais avant marine
il y avait quatre groupes qui avaient
mis en cause de l'europe
les verts ont mis en cause voilà me
merkel directement les conservateurs
britanniques ont mis en cause l'europe
le monsieur faraj a mis en cause de
l'europe en sortir il y a et la manière
aussi
écoute administrateurs la province
france bien sûr que ça met les blogueurs
du troisième reich siderno m'arrêter
avec le troisième reich
il faisait un peu la référence
constructive et la destruction de l'est
de l'europe
c'est une destruction vous vous trompez
nous ne sommes pas destruction qui
secoue l'europe
nous sommes contre cette europe là ce
système qu'il existe notre modèle
européenne des nations qui soient
respectueux des frontières de la liberté
des peuples tout en créant en commun des
projets pour l'avenir et pour l'économie
notamment
elle est décernée par l'un des clubs du
monde du 21e siècle
le général de gaulle le cher monsieur
vous attribuez pas l'europe des nations
l'europe des nations
si les libertés sur votre goût nous
avons représenté 24 députés selon 74
députés eurodéputés français et c'est
pour ça que vous êtes là en tout cas
madame messieurs je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à la
semaine prochaine pour trouver nos
ramadi à cette même place d'ici là et
bien bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
on